hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of alexa and friends
my name is jeff blankenberg and i am
your host today uh and today i have the
honor of talking with nico strom
who is a vp and distinguished scientist
from the alexa ai organization nico
thank you so much for being here
uh i'm glad we get an opportunity to do
this so um as
i've mentioned to you previously we
generally start these conversations with
a couple of silly questions and so
if you don't mind i'm going to dive
right into those and then we're going to
kind of move into
what your history is what your your
focus is on voice
and some of the cool things that you're
working on today is that all right
i guess yeah except for the silly
questions but okay
all right all right i promise these will
be painless um so the first one
i don't know if you are a comic book fan
at all but there have been lots of comic
book movies lately in the theaters
uh at least when theaters were open
right and uh one of the things that i
always like to ask people is if you
could pick
any singular superpower for yourself
which one would you pick i see
um infinite intelligence
all right so do you mean that you can
solve any problem or that you have all
the knowledge what is that what does
that mean
i can solve any problem i can
change the rules of physics anything
interesting and uh so this is this feels
near and dear to you so is there some
limitation of physics
that you wish you could change the speed
of light is a problem for me
really i think yeah uh very
i don't know many people that are on a
daily basis affected by the speed of
light but i would love to know more
about that
any any deeper explanation well it's
bothering me that you know people are
starting to say that we cannot actually
colonize other star systems because
they're too far away
yeah that's really that's really
annoying it is
and the speed of light really gets in
the way of that and
maybe it's the human's capacity to
travel at the speed of light also that
might also be the issue um but yeah that
that's interesting i
uh i think that the idea of colonizing
other places
um probably starting with the moon is an
incredibly interesting endeavor for
uh humanity to try to take on uh but the
idea that we're gonna try and do that
with
mars as well in the relatively near
future is uh that's actually really
exciting to me so
i'm interested to see where that will
all go would you would you go
i know that they've had conversations
about taking volunteers to go to mars
for the first
um human uh mars exploration
like five or seven years from now and
that there is
there's a serious expectation that you
may not come back
yeah that's a problem for me i i also
hear that
there's a good likelihood that you'll
die in excruciatingly
excruciating pain so i i don't know
ah yeah that also doesn't sound very
good to me yeah
um all right i have one more question
this one requires a little bit of a
story
uh and then i just need you to make a
choice so
with uh with that um i want you to
imagine you're walking through a large
city um and you are meeting a friend at
a restaurant
that you know is one street over you're
on 18th street you need to get to 19th
street
now traditionally we would just probably
walk down a large city block get to the
corner and walk around
um but you notice that there's this nice
alley and through the alley you can see
the place that you want to go it happens
to be right there
uh now it's a well-lit day there's no
there's no concern for crime or anything
like that uh and you decide you're gonna
walk down this alley to get to the place
that you're going
and as you do that you get about halfway
down the alley and in front of you
between you and the restaurant that
you're trying to go to
emerges a giant horse-sized duck
i want you to imagine a very large duck
as all the aspects of a normal duck
just happens to be the size of a horse
now
if you're like any normal human you say
no thank you and you turn around and
decide you're going to go back out the
way you came into the alley only to
realize that that end has been closed
by 100 duck-sized horses very small
horses
and there's a hundred of them so my
question for you is now you are kind of
trapped in this alley between these two
made-up
uh kinds of creatures but you know that
you have to get out
right and in either way you're probably
going to be encountered with some kind
of scuffle or fight
which direction would you choose to go
and why wow
um what kind of shoes am i wearing what
shoes you've on now
i don't have any shoes on that is your
answer
oh um
yeah i think i'm gonna try to outrun the
huge stock
i'll run the huge duck that seems
reasonable i don't think that ducks
run very well anyway um
and then at that size that's probably
pretty tricky for a dog yeah
uh all right so you're gonna you're just
gonna try and and dodge and go
go around the giant duck i think i go
giant duck every time too
um but very uh very interesting some
people do choose the hundred
uh tiny horses though and that also
seems um
like a challenge i mean just imagine for
a moment you're in a park and all of a
sudden you're surrounded by a hundred
ducks just regular ducks
uh that on its own seems a little
concerning so um
they were horses i think that would be
trickier they've got hooves and
teeth and all sorts of stuff anyway
those are my silly questions thank you
nico for
for humoring me with those oh you're so
welcome
so what i'd like to get into now and our
questions will kind of lead us through
this but i would
like to really think about what your
background was now i know for you
you've you've had a pretty decent
background in
voice and um neural uh
speech recognition stuff like that for
quite a while but a lot of people that
work in the
in this industry including myself did
not come up with that background right i
i've been a software developer most of
my career i kind of stumbled my way into
voice and discover it and it was like
this is amazing i want to work on this
all the time
um but i don't have that traditional
educational background like a lot of
people do but
you seem to and so i'd like to kind of
take people through a journey of what
your background looks like
and give them a feel for kind of how you
got where you are today
so the first one uh i understand that
you went to the kth royal institute of
technology in stockholm that's that's
uh where you started college yeah that's
right
awesome and so that's kind of where you
got started with speech technology from
what i understand you got your phd there
um tell me about how you got into speech
technology in the first place i
understand this is a good story okay
yeah this is going to be a silly story
but
uh here we go um so
you know in college or in in europe we
call them university but
uh they have these uh uh career fair
where companies come and talk about what
it would be like to work at their
company and
departments at the at the university
would do that too
um there was this professor there and he
had he brought this contraption
a wooden contraption it was sort of like
a
and like an instrument but it had a
reed in one end and then it had like uh
resonance cavities made of wood and
and it was it was simulating the
the vocal tract your your mouth and your
throat
and the cavities that form in the end
there and then when you
use it it sounds just like if you like
blow at one end it sounds just like a
human
vowel sound oh wow yeah and
you have one of these devices this
sounds really interesting i don't
unfortunately i wanted to like bring one
and show you but
they have it there so uh this isn't
i might be able to buy a specialty store
i i actually i try to search for it for
this for
for this but i i couldn't find it anyway
so you can't buy it
but but there's also a little you can
pull
a lever or something to change how large
these cavities are
and you can get different different
vowel sounds and so
he could he could uh with this
contraption explain to us
how vowels are formed in
in our vocal tract and and it was
fascinating for me because i've been
you know studying some science physics
and and so on and
you know we speak i've i've spoken for
20 years by then
without ever thinking about how it
actually works
right so that was fascinating that was
there was something like that
that i didn't know about anyway
so you know a few years later when i i
graduated i i went to that department i
remember this and i
i asked if they had any openings
nice and so um the openings you were
looking for was it
was it look you were looking for a job
or were you looking for grad school
what was the hunt there i was looking
for for grad school so that's where i
eventually got my phd got it
very very good and so i know you posted
recently on your linkedin that in
92 i think from like your grad school
time
um you were working on like a full
end-to-end neural asr system
all the way back then even right it
sounds like you've been working on this
stuff for a while
yeah i have so the one of the first
things i did
so they they wanted me to start working
on speech recognition
and and that was going to be my my area
and so neural networks are still
studied back then but it wasn't uh it
wasn't the deep neural networks that
we're working with today but
uh and so my first thought was that you
know
in the brain it's all a big neural
network and that's what's doing speech
recognition so i should be doing that
too so
why not just have one big neural network
that does all of the speech recognition
right
um and so i actually did that i built a
neural network our current neural
network
that we're spiking for words when when
it could hear a word it would spike as
an output for that particular word so it
was a it was an end-to-end network that
did that but it wasn't very accurate i
mean it worked but it wasn't as good as
as the state-of-the-art at the time sure
and there were there were many reasons
for that i realized now uh you know
there were
several inventions that were needed that
hadn't been
uh done yet now like there was a
uh recorded neural networks back then
were really hard to train
because there was an invention called
lscm that came later that
made it a little easier and also the
spiking output of the network for each
word
um there is a there's a what's called a
loss function that's called ctc that
makes that much easier
and then of course we didn't have much
compute power back then
probably so we have today which is
almost here
anymore yeah so so anyway so
so it's not until now like a few years
ago that
folks have actually made that work but i
can say that i did it almost 30 years
ago
and uh didn't work very well but i tried
and so so things like lstm actually can
you can you define us
define that for us what is lstm wow okay
this is like
starting to shape up like a job
interview here um
sorry uh so
lstm is is a let me step back so there's
something called recurrent neural
networks that that can remember
his the history and you use them to like
for
problems that require you to process
data in sequences
those are the that's a recurrent net
neural networks
but they they when you just do the
simplest possible way
when you implement that in a simpler
possible way it's it's hard to train
those networks
uh it's
it's because it's hard to remember
history for a long time
in in the network uh because of noise or
whatnot it's hard
and lstm was a technique to
to make the network a little bit more
complex but
uh make it much more powerful in terms
of
remembering its history got it okay
and so so you got into grad school and
you're working on uh
a number of different things but
as from what i understand part of your
work was creating the first continuous
speech recognizer
for swedish is that is that
yeah i had a lot of help of course there
was a
there was a um a project at
the department at kth for
uh building a dialogue system for
the timetables of ferries in the
stockholm archipelago
you may not know this but outside of
stockholm there are hundreds of small
islands
it's it's very beautiful especially in
the in the summer lots of tourism
and there are uh ferries between all the
islands
and um so they wanted a dialogue system
so you could call
in on the phone and ask when the next
ferry is or or the time for
ferries and so the the department had
this grant to try to do this this is
kind of early days there wasn't
this was cutting edge stuff back then
you know now maybe
this sounds like something that we
already have but back then it was
something that had to be invented um and
so
i helped out doing the speech
recognition system for that uh
dialogue system and that was the that
was the swedish
recognizer that i've been talking about
okay uh very very cool so
um so you got your phd
and then you headed over to mit right
that's right yep um so they were they
were um
can i mention a few things that i did in
my phd too
just because yeah okay cool because i
think uh the system
uh that we built for that that uh ferry
system
um there were a couple new interesting
things that i built there for the speech
recognition system uh
one one was a i combined these recurrent
networks that we talked about the
recurrent neural networks
with something that was called time
delay networks
today that's called convolutional
network so i combine those two
architectural features in one network
and
you know today that sounds kind of
obvious but back then it was uh
it was new and you know it was fun to
work on
um and the other
i think that there were three things i
did and the other the other second thing
was um
computation was the problem as we talked
about that you know
we didn't have as powerful computers so
uh i figured out a way of pruning all
the connections in the network so that
the network become became more
compact and we could train the network
much faster and we could
run it faster so that it would run in in
real time for the system
um oh and the third thing we worked on
uh was um speaker adaptation so
speech recognition works better if you
adapt to the
the current customer's voice right so
uh what what i did there was i i came up
with this concept of a speaker
vector space and uh it's
it's really similar to what people call
embeddings today
so there was an embedding for uh
each speaker so you have a vector that
represents each speaker and then
you pass that on to the speed
recognition system and it would
uh it would use that to condition the
result and get better accuracy
got it anyways sorry i interrupted you
you wanted to talk about mit but
i know you're trying to take that
journey through
through where you were so that was part
of your phd work
and then um after your phd you uh
it sounds like you went to mit so i'd
love to know more about kind of what
you're
there right so the department had good
uh
connections to the speech group the
spoken language systems group at mit and
they uh
connected with me with me with uh jim
glass
there he's a he's a professor in speech
recognition so i worked with him
on a postdoc project to make their
dialogue system
to improve their dialogue system um i
got to learn a little bit about a
different type of speech recognition
system
so that was that was exciting
one one other thing that is not speech
recognition that i worked on there
which is fun is i worked on
what's called turn taking so you know if
you use
an automatic dialog system you kind of
have to follow a very linear
dialog flow you have to say one thing
then wait a little bit and then the
system talks and then you wait and then
so humans don't really do that right
i i think you and i have already
interrupted each other a couple of times
so so what i was working on was to try
to make the dialogue system more like
humans to
accept cross speed to you know have have
back channeling voices uh
to you know acknowledge that you're
understanding what the other person is
saying
and um maybe even use visual cues
so i i wrote an early paper and
experiments with that
and that was exciting to me yeah
that is interesting is that is that kind
of a precursor for some of the dialogue
stuff that we see today in alexa
are those early days of that same kind
of work i think
you're going to see in the future you're
going to see in alexa a lot of exciting
things in that area but we haven't
really launched them yet
got it got it got it but those are those
are things we're still doing research on
today
yeah excellent all right so
your next stop after mit was tell me and
i i find this interesting
not because you work to tell me but it
seems like
there was a time at which all of the
the brightest minds in voice all somehow
found their way to tell me at some point
uh and it's just always interesting to
me when i talk with folks like you that
have this rich background in
voice your path also led through tell me
it was like there's a lot of
a lot of amazing research and a lot of
amazing individuals that have all come
out of that company at some point um
so maybe first let's start with for
those people that aren't aware of it can
you tell people just a little bit about
what tell me was at least back in like
the early 2000s
yeah and then how that kind of what what
you learned as
as part of that process oh yeah uh
let's so so tell me networks was um
well first of all this was the internet
boom area around 2000 right
everyone wanted to start i built a
startup and everyone wanted to work in a
startup
and everyone was going to get rich fast
and um
so uh around 2000 we
we got a bit big surprise but that's a
different story
so so that was that time and i was
really excited about the internet
and what what tell me the promise of
tell me was that
the telephony and internet
are two technologies that are colliding
that are bound to be
joined right and so the founder mike
mchugh
[Music]
had that idea that he was he was
building a company around that idea
and the first thing that they wanted to
build was
a place a browser for the internet but
for the phone so you could call
a special number and you can get all the
kinds of information that you were
getting on the internet back then
and uh back then it was uh portals was
what what you used so you use the yahoo
portal for example and then you would go
to weather
or sports or whatever and uh and so
this was a this became a voice portal
uh so that was the start that that was
how how tell me started
um later
uh the company pivoted towards uh
serving 1-800 numbers for companies like
their customer service numbers
and also doing the 4-1-1
service for for phone companies running
that so that was
that was telling me i regarding lessons
i learned so many things this is my
first job outside of academia and
[Music]
i can't really enumerate all of them but
it was a startup
of course and it followed this
eight-year arc
of first it grew really fast and there
was a pivot and then we were finding a
market fit
and we matured and finally it was
acquired by microsoft right
so there's a a good success story
um but apart from the last part where it
got acquired
i feel like alexa has been a very
similar experience for me
it you know we started out i joined when
we started very small it grew like a
startup within
amazon yeah well that's uh can you
remember when did you start at amazon
i started around 2011. okay
so that was for four and a half years or
so before
the product was actually available to
the public
yes that's right all right so it takes
some time to build something like this
yeah um
so uh but to pick one thing perhaps and
you mentioned this too there were a lot
of great people working at
tell me i think one of the
one of the unexpected things that i
learned a lot from the creative teams
like the
the voice uh um
the voice production teams the ui
teams and for example uh you've had a
couple of those two folks
i think already in in your interviews
here right
uh so so that that gave me a lot of uh
the foundation for now
how i think about you know customer
experience
got it and so um
i i do as you as you came from tell me
how many of those people like i
mentioned earlier
work at amazon now um
but as you as you think about the work
back then that you were doing
at a place like tell me is is there
anything different about how you think
about things like
the systems the output how how a lot of
these pieces are together
um then versus well
there are lots of differences um the
underlying technologies has gotten much
better so we can we can
do many more things we can uh asr the
speech recognition system
can recognize many more things
you know becoming much broader in the
kind of things that you can ask the
system
uh back in in the tell me days it was
more like menu driven
um so it would recognize a dozen things
or or so and but now you know it's open
you can
you can ask alexa anything from the
get-go
from all the different domains that we
have and and in one shot you can get
something done
that's one thing uh another interesting
thing was that
the output the text to speech output
was not as good back then it
it worked but it wasn't sounding as
natural as as it does
today and so we had a recording studio
so for every
every output we had to have someone
record it so we had a voice talent
that was working really hard because she
was uh
she was essentially doing all the output
of of the telnet system at the time
but now because of because of
advancements in machine learning and
deep learning
our systems can actually speak
uh so naturally from the automated
output that
we can use that instead and and that is
is uh uh our team
our team for text-to-speech is really in
the forefront of the
the deep learning technologies there
that's that's cool so i'm i'm going to
try to explain this and you're going to
tell me where i'm wrong
so my understanding of those early days
when you had voice talent actually
recording things
that you would be trying to get all of
the different
phonemes the different sounds that a
human could make
um and then you would ultimately when
you when you had to go to
each you would then compose um an audio
file made up of all of those individual
chunks
uh that would be stitched together and
delivered to the user and so sometimes
they didn't sound exactly perfect but
they
the word came out where today it's far
more synthesized right this is an actual
synthetic voice
that sounds a lot like that original one
um
and we're generating that on the fly is
that an accurate representation it is
but there's one more thing but but yes
it is
so today so what you described was the
the text-to-speech technology that we
had back then you would
concatenate little snippets of recorded
audio right
today there's a neural network that
decides
each sample so 16 000 or more
times per second it decides what the
output should be
excuse me wow did you say
it could be more like it's the sample
frequency of the audio so
it's thousands of times per second the
system will have to decide exactly what
that
what the output should be but but
there's more to it because
we we were not satisfied with that
technology
back then it didn't sound natural enough
so what we really did was for everything
for every possible thing that the system
should output
the voice talent will record exactly
that as one
one prompt
oh man so so it wasn't that you were
just building a library you were
actually building libraries of phrases
too
yep oh my goodness yeah that can become
a logistical nice
nightmare quickly i would imagine
okay so we talked about amazon in 2011
and how you joined there
um so you you first get to amazon
it's not like there are echo devices on
millions of kitchen counters
when you start so what was it like what
were you working on what
how does it start and like what were
some of the the challenges that you guys
faced as you
first started building this alexa engine
yeah
well part of the part of the story is
that
when you join a future project like this
that's not going to launch in the near
future it's going to be
a secret project we don't want to we
don't want it to leak right so
they wouldn't even tell me what it was
before i joined so i
i ca i had to take a leap of faith
uh when when greg and frederick
recruited me
that it was going to be good for me and
they
they convinced me that yes you're going
to work on speech technologies but
that's really all i knew
and so when when then when i joined
there's this reveal
you get disclosed on the project and
they told me what it was that
you're going to have to do speech
recognition
from across the room in a noisy room
with reverberation and it's someone's
home so you don't need
you don't know what's in there and you
know what it's like
and and that was very that was a scary
moment for me because i had no idea how
to do that no one knew how to do that
right
so uh but then when you got over that it
was also
super exciting because it's like it's a
dream you have to you have a blank slate
you you get to build a product from
scratch um
you get good uh some great uh co-workers
to do it so
so after that it was pretty awesome so
what you're describing is something that
we
have have used the word far field
recognition for
was was this a problem that anyone was
working on previously because i would
imagine a lot of the speaker
speech recognition being done at least
the research was probably done in a
clean auditory environment i just wanted
it to work it wasn't about like adding
all this extra noise i wanted it to just
work at all
i know well this the technology started
with a very clean speech and then uh
it had moved to telephony speech which
is less clean but it's still
you know your mouth is very close to the
microphone so there's no
reverberation problems and and you get a
strong signal
but no one had really tackled this
problem it just seemed too
hard to work on um
on far field speech especially when you
don't have no
control at all over over the environment
right because
it's in someone else's millions of homes
where they're all different
uh so this is all new and um
lots of problems arise uh we train our
systems using data right
and because no one had worked on it
there was no data so we needed so that
was one of the big challenges
wow um so we had to collect that on our
own
um but in addition to the
data problem um
we had to find ways to get the accuracy
up
and one of the things we worked on was
adapting to the speaker's voice
which i i talked about that i had worked
on earlier in my career
uh and um
but but this did i mention the uh
this the switch to deep neural networks
that happened around the same time
i joined the amazon no um so the the
industry
and um the speech recognition
field uh was sort of really invigorated
at that site at that time because there
was this new
uh system architecture that was based on
deep neural networks
uh that was emerging and accuracy
got much better uh when you use that uh
the only problem was that it was a whole
new different paradigm so you'd have to
retool
your systems and you had to relearn a
lot of things
uh so that was one of the one of the
most important things we were working at
at that time to make that work so we
were participating in
in in this global wave of deep learning
in asr and
it paid off it made the system work much
better and it was probably
one one of the things that made the echo
devices successful in the end
that's that's excellent that's a great
story to tell
uh all right so one of the things i
you've written a paper on the idea of
taking these deep neural networks
um and addressing uh communication
bottleneck
um what the training problem is what the
the deep neural network training problem
is and then
kind of what's your approach what your
method is for getting around this
bottleneck
yeah so when we decided we wanted to
to try to do this change from the older
paradigm to deep neural networks
uh there were many things that had to be
invented and changed
one was that the old involved paradigm
the
the models could be easily trained with
something called the em algorithm which
which is easily paralyzed it's a batch
algorithm
uh that can that that can be paralyzed
in two steps
and by paralyzed parallelized i mean it
can be run
on hundreds or thousands of different uh
computer hosts at the same time okay so
you get the power of all of them right
when we were training deep neural
networks at the time
that was hard and uh typically you would
you would instead you would use a gpu
which it
in itself is very powerful but it's only
one of them
so so we knew that
to scale this to much larger models much
larger data sizes we would eventually
have to figure out how to parallelize
over many gpus using the
the neural network training algorithms
which were not based on the same
algorithm so they were much harder to
parallelize
and there was this and there's this
communication problem when they
when you have multiple gpus they have to
communicate results so that they can
eventually produce a single
model
so that was also something that wasn't
really
solved at a time anywhere and
we had to figure out how to do it we had
lots of gpus
in aws that we could use but uh
we needed to figure out how to make them
work in parallel
and so well the way that that i sold
that was i figured out a way to
select exactly which part of the
information is most important
and send that and also send it in a very
compressed form
and so that was one of the first
papers on undoing this i'm paralyzing
uh over many gpus and it
uh since then it's that
area has been become very large and
there's a there's a
very rich literature on that now there's
many other techniques to do it
and but that was one of the first wow
uh talking with a pioneer this is
fantastic so for those of you that may
have just joined us
i'm speaking with nico strom who's a vp
and distinguished scientist here at
amazon
on the alexa ai team uh and so we were
just talking about
one of the papers that you wrote you
said um this paper didn't actually come
out until a bit later because you were
in the middle of
launching everything else working so how
what was the line between like your
your foundational research and
understanding and then being able to
actually publish your paper
i i figured it was about two years maybe
18 months or two years
okay that sounds about right i mean it's
still soon enough but i think that's
that's an interesting little twist on
that is that like i have all this cool
research but i'm so busy implementing it
that i can't even
share my findings i i think so today
there is a lot of uh research there's
very fast research in machine learning
today people are
worried that they will be scooped
someone else will publish it before them
sure and so uh that's a little different
way of thinking about it but uh
um
i think that the things that we work on
in alexa
uh are so unique that
we won't we don't get scooped even if we
wait a year
because uh we're working on our own uh
challenging problems and we can we can
uh take our time to develop the idea
and then write a really good paper and
publish it at least
that's how i like it so this is this is
based entirely only on my own
assumptions here but i have to imagine
you were probably involved in many
different
patents as well as you went through this
process
yes this is correct we got these blue
puzzle pieces as a reward
when we when we get when we get uh and
and uh they have the patent number on
them and you can
you can build a big puzzle out of them
and yeah i don't even know how many i
have but it's a big puzzle now
that's amazing i will tell you i've been
in amazon almost five years i have zero
um so if you're looking to share some
puzzle pieces i'd be happy to get
involved no i
think that's uh that's that's very very
interesting
um so we're we're gonna take a jump back
to
um the lstm stuff i know that uh you
also talked about you know scaling
machine learning
uh in ski in speech recognition
experiments can you tell me more about
the
the research you've done around that
oh uh yeah um well
a few years ago hari pogtasari and i did
an interesting study we we were scaling
speech recognition to
a million hours of training data so that
was the
it's hard to know you know what what's
happening in proprietary companies but
out of all the published results there
was an order of magnitude more data than
anyone had used before
so um the trick
in that case was that we were training
the model using no
human labeling in an attack technique
that's called semi supervised so you
have
it's a it's a learning loop where you
have a system that's trained
on some data that's annotated by humans
and then you use that system
to automatically annotate a much larger
uh
data set make sense and then you iterate
and you train on that
so we use that technique and
you mentioned lstms that was the the
technique
sorry the architecture of the model that
we trained and
uh of course when you use a lot more
data you you hope to get
better accuracy out of the system better
less errors
and and we got uh we got a good we got
some good results we got
10 to 20 improvements on on the accuracy
which is
quite significant but but the the
interesting part of that project was
more
not so much exactly the precise
improvements but it was
we demonstrated that you could do large
scale
unsupervised that's when you don't have
annotations
training uh for asr and uh
we solved all all the different
engineering problems as well that
arise when you have to work with so much
data right and so
um i think the the more that's the more
lasting impact of that to that work i
think
oh very cool uh all right we're gonna
jump a little bit further forward
i know one of the things that um you've
spent some time on is the idea of
on on-device asr uh this is something
that is
uh i'm often asked about quite quite
frequently as
i go out and talk about alexa and
building skills and thinking about
building experiences for voice
people often ask me what is happening on
the device what is happening in the
cloud
and how are those different and just for
clarity for
for our audience the way alexa works
today is that a recording is made
locally on the device but all of the asr
all the other processing happens
in the cloud it's just we're just
shipping off an audio file um but
i know that there are a lot of people
that would really like that capability
to be able to do
things locally on the device about all
the time so
what's your perspective on device asr
[Music]
it's funny um so today
people talk about this a lot in
isolation you know we should we should
do more processing on
on the edge we should do processing on
devices but
this is not new um
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna use a
quote that they say a lot of the in the
tv show battlestar galactica
galactica so um they say a lot all of
this has happened before
and all of this will happen again and i
i think about that quote when people
talk about the edge because
um the pendulum has already swung a
couple of times
you know initially we had uh maybe mini
computers
and then and then in the 80s you know
there was a new paradigm of a personal
computer starting to show up and
and that happened at the same time as
visual graphical user interfaces happen
right and and it's easy to
understand why you have to have more
computation on the edge to do visual
uh gui right because you need the
latency you can't
move the mouse and then you know wait
for a few seconds for the data to be
processed
in some server and then it'll come back
so
so it's often often the driver for edge
confusing
computing is the user experience and the
latency on the edge
and of course uh and then
there was this swing back to the cloud
when you know cloud computing became
popular aws uh rose and there was the
big data
trend and lots of things happened that
made
a swing back and for for machine
learning
it's really nice to have all the data in
the cloud because we can train models
and make the system better for customers
but now now again there's just
this swing back towards the edge because
we want
lower latency for speech recognition for
example
so so uh our teams are working
a lot in this area we're in the in the
front end of this
next uh switch towards computation in
the cloud
but i think we we have uh some some
really interesting things that are
coming up and
unfortunately i can't share it today but
i think uh we will share it
soon excellent excellent
uh yeah i think i think there's some
there's some exciting things that go on
when we think about
doing on-device asr and being able to
handle all that but the the
complications there from my
my novice mind about how this science
works um
i mean you need a model you need
training you need a vast amount of
resources to understand and process some
of this stuff
and to be able to push all of that out
to the edge seems really
incredibly challenging without some sort
like the way i would imagine doing it
would be that i would have regular
updates that just got pushed out as we
continue to improve and grow the model
and we just we hope for the best on that
individual model locally but
um that's a really interesting problem
to try to solve
indeed ah i'm not going to try to solve
it here today jeff
but no no no no nor would i expect you
to
um on uh well first let me mention that
if you guys haven't
uh if you enjoy these kind of
conversations and you you like talking
with scientists and learning about what
they're working on
uh we have a fantastic blog uh that is
the amazon science blog you can find it
at amazon.science
um but i know nico you've contributed to
this a few times with different articles
and one specifically about
the faint mathematician alan turing who
you know uh
at least gave the name to the turing
test which many science
computer scientists here may be uh aware
of uh
can you tell us more about what how you
view that turing test today and
how we continue to change the goal posts
on that yeah
sorry some i have a noise here
sorry about that uh yeah um
i think uh you know today
uh it's it's uh a little out of date
i think uh so it's natural to measure
intelligence
with humans as a yardstock because you
know humans are
clearly the most intelligent thing or
being that we know
of so you would do that and it's similar
to how we
still measure car engines by horsepowers
i think
right but it's kind of limiting to think
about intelligence
as being the same thing as being human
and i think
for when you think about artificial
intelligence that that
can be problematic and i think it's a
trap that many might fall in even if
they don't even realize that they they
they fall in that trap right and in that
blog i try to make that point and i took
a very
particular point of view
uh anyway sorry i
lost my my train of thought but uh in
the blog i took
i took that view and i stuck with it
it's a little bit more complex than that
of course but i try to make it
make it interesting um
the i my day job is i'm a scientist i'm
an engineer and i use ai
to build ai applications that are useful
for amazon customers right but there's
there's a fascinating part of this
discussion that's that's about what you
just
described that is sort of more
philosophical and metaphysical
you
you know you've heard the expression you
know
airplanes don't flap their wings right
it's a little bit like that
um we can learn a lot from
biological intelligence i think and we
do and the ai field has learned a lot
but it's not necessarily the same thing
yeah no i like so yeah good i think and
you you mentioned
philosophical approaches to this i think
there is an interesting philosophical
question there
which is that if i can build a computer
system that is imperceivable
as whether or not as human
is it right or is it just pretending
um yeah and from my perspective my my
personal philosophy on this is that
um i don't know that that's the question
that needs to be answered
about is can can it do the things that
it needs to do
and if it's pretending to be human in
order to do it i'm
i'm absolutely okay with that yeah
alexa is interesting though because
alexa for alexa
alexa's job is sort of to be a
like a human we want to communicate with
alexa
and the things that happen
after that is usually
not very human uh but the communication
the interaction with the system is
is what we're striving for is a is a
natural human conversational ability
right
uh we're working on things like uh
com natural conversation empathy and so
on
we're not at all at human level in those
tasks but if you think about
what alexa can do she's actually super
human in many ways
like alexa if you have multiple devices
in your home alexa is at many places at
the same time
which you can't be right she knows the
time to the second
or better all the time which
i don't uh and you know you solve
complex math
problems in in milliseconds and so on so
she's already better than human in some
ways but
in in the communication in the empathy
and so on not so much right so that's
fair
well one example i always like to use is
that um as much as i
tend to do this in my house because i
have children that just won't do it
i can't turn off every light switch all
the time right like i have to go
travel to those places i can't turn off
all the lights at once
uh although my children well to no end
will never turn a light switch off
anyway um as as we go through that
process you realize that like
those are capabilities that humans don't
have at all
and i think that's a that's a fantastic
perspective on it
so um naacl n double acl
uh how is that conference prayer is it n
double a
well people call it knuckles sometimes
that's that's perfect
one of the things that i really struggle
with when we talk about big events like
this is if you've only ever read it you
don't know how to pronounce it
uh kneckel uh is coming up in two weeks
and i know that you uh you have a paper
on alexa conversations coming up
uh is there anything you can share what
we're gonna learn from your paper
the paper is a systems uh paper uh that
describes uh
our alexa conversations system
it it's our new way of doing
um dialogue management of
you know multi-term dialogues for for
alexa
i think if you think about how people
use alexa
in in most cases it's a one-shot command
you tell alexa to do something and it
happens
there is there's an opportunity to do
much more though there are
lots of things that we want to do that
you can't just do with one
command if you want to research
something
if you want to uh
use a more complicated transaction like
buying some tickets for a movie
that requires you to give a lot of
information it would be very
difficult to say all that information in
a single command right so
so dialogue i think is going to be more
and more important for solving those
types of
problems and and in in the paper we
outline our
vision for how we want to do dialogue in
the future and how
we've already launched that in alexa
conversations for
for developers it's it's a more
end-to-end machine learning
way of doing dialogue it's more
open-ended
developers give examples of dialogues
rather than
explicitly coding
exactly which state goes to the it's not
a
a flow graph right or a floating chart i
think that's good for those
those people that are watching that are
developers uh we announced alexa
conversations
almost a year ago last year at alexa
live
and it is it's it's that kind of there's
a machine learning engine behind
how your conversations are driven and i
think that's that's a really interesting
approach and it's something that i
continue to see you guys kind of grow
and expand
um as we learn more and as we can
implement uh more to it so i'm very
excited to see the future of alexa
conversations
all right so um as we look forward
what are some of the things for you and
obviously you're far deeper into this
than most are
but when you look at the field of ai and
where it's headed
what are the things that you're really
excited about
right so
stepping back 10 years to when the when
i mentioned that there was this
switch in asr from from an older
paradigm to deep learning that sort of
that change happened across many fields
around the same time deep learning
methods became
prevalent everywhere and uh
right now we're in this exciting period
where there's this cross-pollination
between many different
fields uh and there's a lot of uh
invention because of it before that i
feel like we were more in a
sort of post-paradigm period where there
were small changes
uh every year incremental changes but
but uh the last 10 years has seen a lot
more innovation about
more dynamics in in machine learning
so that that sets the stage for
for all the exciting things i think at
the macro level
and before we dive into that i mean
you've called that out a few times
during our conversation the idea that
over the last 10 years
things have advanced at a far rap more
rapid rate than they have before
if you like one thing that was the
biggest contributor to that acceleration
what is that
oh wow so i i can't really boil it down
to one thing but i think because of
many other factors uh we now
have a machine learning
landscape where scientists from many
different fields are
more and more starting to use the same
tools so
uh you know we can cross-pollinate
across
many so there's many more ideas
available because all the scientists
from
all the fields can pool their ideas into
machine learning solutions and and they
rapidly
you know propagate through other other
fields
which wasn't really the case before
got it okay so so if we wanted to boil
it way down
the answer might just be the internet
right the the ability to collaborate and
communicate and share this kind of
research and knowledge
uh that's certainly one of the things
yeah okay excellent
excellent excellent um all right so i
interrupted you
what are those things about ai that
you're really excited about
oh um
well for the future it's really exciting
that we're now actually starting to
uh solve problems that
just a few years ago we didn't think
were solvable and for
if you think about a general ai we
talked about that a little bit earlier
what what intelligence means
we now have things like
autonomous delivery drones we have
cars that drive themselves
and i think it's just the beginning so
we are learning how to
build systems like that that can
be trained on data whether it's
supervised or unsupervised
more and more data and and and we are
going to get intelligent systems all
around us and
it's going to once we live in that world
like maybe
15 years from now where where that has
sort of played out
there's going to be ai everywhere and i
think that's when
[Music]
that's when we can start to revisit that
discussion about what
intelligence is and whether intelligence
can be
human only or because because it's hard
to
envision now i think when you don't live
in that world quite yet
right um but but i think that that
just thinking about that future is
pretty exciting
i i agree and so i'd love to get you if
you can
to give a little more color to that
specific answer you said
you imagine a future where ai is
everywhere and i think everybody will
probably interpret that a little
differently do you have
like a very specific example of how you
imagine ai
would impact us as humans
um so ai can be embodied and it can be
not embodied so
all the things i mentioned earlier were
mostly embodied there's a car
there's a drone but of course there's
there's
a robot uh your roomba or
but uh there's
there's also intelligence that just sits
in the cloud and solves problems for us
there's
you know uh there's already ai's that
can solve some
some mathematical problems that have
been outstanding for many years
uh and and it's penetrating
all all sciences like physics and
biology
all of those things we're going to see
humans working together with ais and
solving really hard and important
problems i think i love that
uh that sounds like a world i want to
live in i like that very much
uh all right so i i have one one last
question for you
um and it kind of gets away from your
research a little bit and focuses more
on your role and your experience here at
amazon
but there are scientists watching right
now right as we broadcast this
and there are always people thinking
about maybe they want to join the alexa
team or they want to get involved with
amazon science in some way
do you have advice for people that are
thinking about that and two
what stands out for you when you in when
you meet people that are interested in
science roles at amazon
um let me start with uh
what what my advice is i think you want
to learn
about amazon and and it's easy to learn
about amazon
you know we have our culture is actually
a very open and
we are explicit about what we think our
culture should be and it's encoded
in for example in the leadership
principles and they they're easy to find
on the internet you can find amazon
leadership principles there
you can you can learn about them and
then you learn a lot about amazon
um other things you can learn about the
the culture is uh there's some
there's a meme or it's always day one
um there's even a building in
an amazon tower that's called day one um
and and uh because i find it interesting
that it
the day one building is not the first
building that was called day one
uh i don't i need to change the building
that is day one which i just find
humorous
yeah uh but day one just to clarify day
one
is uh what it means is you know even
though
we're one of the largest companies in
the world
uh we we need to stay nimble uh even as
we grow
and uh jeff bezos explains this really
well there's
videos on the internet you can look up
if you want to if you want to see how he
explains it
much better than i do um
another advice i would have is that
amazon we think about
we think about builders and we think
about dreamers but
sorry about this but um
but you really have to be both a builder
and a dreamer at amazon
so we we const we constantly we dream up
new things like alexa
big things uh amazon go where you don't
you just walk out after you shopping
uh autonomous delivery drones and so on
but they're also smaller innovations
like
everyone participates in this it's not
just the big ones
so to be successful at amazon you have
to
dream big and you have to channel that
that
innovation to things that benefit
customers
if you can do that then you do well but
dreaming
is not enough of course you also have
that that drive to want to build things
you want to be a builder as well
we follow through and we realize those
dreams in real products so
if you can be both those things uh then
i think
amazon is the place for you awesome
well nico i want to thank you for
joining me today uh i can't believe that
we've already gotten to the top of our
hour if anyone would like to know more
about what nico and his team are working
on
they publish papers and blog posts and
all sorts of interesting research
over at amazon.science which is where
they
compile all of their their great
information
um it should give you a little more
flavor about you know what they're doing
at alexa ai and some of the things that
they're working on
i i enjoy going there uh it's not core
to what i do every day
but it's so interesting to understand
how they use it how they think about it
what the research is that they're doing
uh it helps you kind of paint a picture
for where you think things might be
going or how the the future could look
for all of us
uh so nico thank you again uh so much
yeah
um all right so with that we are done
for today uh i have a quick
video that i'll play as we uh as we
leave here today but thank you guys all
for tuning in it is always my pleasure
to get to meet
some amazing people working in the world
of alexa so thank you guys all for
tuning in
and we will see you very soon one of the
things that i love about working for
amazon as a data scientist
i get time to research ideas come up
with proposals
develop solutions and really innovate in
my role
hi there my name is kaelin lee i am a
data science manager in amazon i lead a
team of business intelligence engineers
data engineers and data scientists and
we provide
uh scientific and analytical solutions
to serve alexa music initiatives
my name is constantinos papianes i'm an
applied scientist and i've worked in the
alexa hml
team for almost two years now my name is
jinding
i'm a proud scientist in amazon now i'm
in prime video finance team my name is
patrick
i'm a data scientist and amazon's
networking team based here in sydney
my name is julian pachon and i am the
director and chief scientist for amazon
smart
scientists and amazon owners um the fun
part of my job is to turn data-driven
evidence into business decision making
we love trying out new ideas for example
this could be a new way of slicing the
data it could be a new tool to process
the data
it could be another methodology for
comparison purposes
or just a whole new business problems to
solve customer obsession
help us make sure we're focusing on
actual customer needs
things that customers would use in their
day-to-day lives and that would
make their lives better we're not
limited to the problem we want the
project to solve
we also think about how these projects
can benefit other amazon team
or the open source community as a
science team
the principle that i value the most is
invent and simplify
you know our job is to innovate we need
to constantly look for new ways of how
to do things
and so we experiment a lot in the
experimentation we also
fail a lot and but we aim to fail fast
and when we do that
then we drive innovation
you